[MUSIC PLAYING]
EMILY FORTUNA: It has been
a jam I/O show this year,
and I'm sorry it's already over.
TIMOTHY JORDAN: Right?
I mean, we've covered so much.
It's been an amazing three days.
EMILY FORTUNA: Thank you all for
tuning in and experiencing it
with us.
Though we're
wrapping up this I/O,
keep the conversation
going with #io19.
TIMOTHY JORDAN: And to
watch all the keynotes,
all of the sessions, and
all the I/O live content,
visit g.co/io/live or head
directly to the Google
Developers YouTube channel.
EMILY FORTUNA: And to
stay connected with Google
Developers, sign up
for our newsletter
at g.co/dev/newsletter.
TIMOTHY JORDAN: So
long from I/O 2019.
EMILY FORTUNA: See you in 2020.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
SPEAKER 1: Good
morning, Shoreline.
Welcome to Google I/O.
SUNDAR PICHAI: Thank you all
for joining us in person.
And to the millions around the
world watching on Livestream.
SPEAKER 2: Right, experiments.
Let's go check it out.
Vroom, vroom, vroom.
SPEAKER 3: Today, there are
over 2.5 billion active Android
devices.
SPEAKER 4: The vibe's great,
the people here are amazing.
SPEAKER 5: The sessions,
the food, the people,
everything's perfect.
SPEAKER 6: 10 years.
10 years of our Google
Developer community.
SPEAKER 7: Each of you
do so much to help.
We appreciate everything
you do for us.
SPEAKER 8: Here is our friend.
[LAUGHTER]
SPEAKER 9: It's an AR shark.
It won't bite.
[LAUGHING]
SPEAKER 10: Oh, that's so nifty!
SUNDAR PICHAI: It's
a perfect example
of what we mean
by building a more
helpful Google for everyone.
[MUSIC PLAYING]